peu plus
nous avons tous peur de quelque chose
sans trop savoir pourquoi cela s'appelle
une phobie mais pour certains
la barre puisque les empêcher de vie
c'est surréaliste
j'ai 35 ans et je vais tout seul j'avais
la phobie des serpents c'était la
paralysie totale je dire j'étais
incapable d'entrer dans une pharmacie
s'il y avait une poignée en forme de
serpent
je peux pas passer dans un couloir de
métro s'il y avait eu les murs tapissés
de publicité avec des serpents je ne
rencontre pas très souvent dans la vie
des serpents
avec l'aide des publicitaires on en
rencontre de plus en plus et ça pousse
quand même des problèmes aux gens qui
sont phobique des serpents et se
manifester comment
physiquement je pouvais plus me
contrôler je veux dire j'avais tellement
peur que je pouvais plus avancer dans un
couloir de métro que si je méritais un
magazine je jetais de magazines en
guerre où je me mettais à crier je veux
dire il ya absolument je pouvais pas
m'en empêcher j'avais peur il ya une
vraie peur des phobiques vous connaissez
l'origine de cette phobie nom puis ça
m'intéresse moi pas de le savoir
mais vous avez cherché
au nom pauvrement je veux dire je ne me
rappelle pas avoir jamais eu pied report
et puis bon si l'originalité que ça
m'intéresse franchement pas de manger
sur un divan pendant dix ou quinze ans
pour savoir qui se calculent de nec a
peur des serpents
c'était simplement pour moi c'était un
handicap dans ma vie aussi bien dans ma
vie quotidienne parce qu'on ne veut
peut-être du mal à y croire mais tous
les fans des serpents rhume comprend
brand même dans une grande ville
d'impayés de tempérer des serpents on en
voit partout et puis aussi dans ma vie
professionnelle
j'avais peur quand j'allais dans
certains pays de me trouve en tête à
tête avec un serpent c'est quand même
pas ce qui est le plus drôle et c'est la
seule fabrique vous ayez oui ça c'est
fini
je suis psychiatre je pratique les
thérapies comportementales
alors pour vous c'est quoi une phobie et
bien une phobie la définition la plus
simple c'est
c'est une peur disproportionné par
rapport à son objet 5 les gens ont peur
d'une situation où d'un objet d'une
façon beaucoup plus intense qu'ils ne
devraient normalement et ce qui
caractérise la phobie c'est le conte ce
qu'on appelle le comportement
d'évitement c'est à dire que les gens
fuient la situation qui leur fait peur
d'une façon absolument système est
moi j'ai trente trois ans qui gagne pas
ma vie parce que je peux la gagner parce
que vos données publiques va comme moi
je vais travailler est arrivé à un
moment je suis resté pendant plusieurs
mois complètement enfermée chez moi ne
plus rien pouvoir faire mais strictement
rien vous aviez peur de quoi
je ne pouvais pas sortir parce que je me
disais si je sors tu vas voir en vidéo
le cabinet aura lieu au cabinet devant
des gens je ne peux pas les hôtes et
binette voit des gens c'est pas possible
c'est hésiter je sais pas moins probable
de mettre à poil devant cinquante
personnes bombe ne sera que du feu rien
qu'en mai mais de daleo shot demander
par exemple quelqu'un est ce que je peux
le roux sont les toilettes ou un truc
comme ça c'était impossible
quand vous pensez vous en sortir parce
que cette
sortie par une thérapie
manille
en quoi consistait le traitement
dans un premier temps
ça consiste est demandé partout où
j'allais faire d'abord dans des cafés
demandé où étaient les toilettes que
j'ai envie ou non d'y aller pour me
disant quoi c'est
pourquoi c'était de faire perdre frank
donc comme ça ne m'était jamais arrivé
le docteur m'a dit puisque ça ne vous
est jamais arrivé saleh de faire de
votre propre et donc c'est comme ça que
j'ai
ça s'est passé
donc vous avez commencé à faire dans
votre culotte et salim le cirque au
début c'était pas angoissant presse a
fait beau ça fait monter énormément une
romande angoisse près l'angoissent à
plafonner après le roi
a commencé à descendre et puis après
avoir pendant plusieurs mois ces cétacés
dire que maintenant est ce que vous êtes
plus ou moins libéré de ce groupe i
tunes et moussy pdg c'est fini aussi
prédit
une femme libérée comme vous dites
[Musique]
alors je m'appelle bernard et
je suis éducateur canin c'est à dire que
je m'occupe de chiens j'habite à avignon
ainsi pas mariée je suis même
complètement célibataire donc pas
d'enfant la phobie c'est simplement une
peur d'eux
une perte de m'étouffer qui est pas
permanente mais qui se retrouve très
souvent et notamment au moment de
moments de m'alimenter pour expliquer
plus rapidement j'ai peur que
l'alimentation ne veut pas ce parcours
par le mauvais chemin c'est à dire les
rôles est passé par les dauphins est ce
que ça passe par la trachée
enfin c'est à peine vraisemblable
justement je suis pas sûr que non parce
que j'ai été j'ai vu une fois une
affiche qui en parlait justement qui
était assez grosses pour qu'on la voit
c'est une affiche qui était dans un
centre médical et qui mettait en garde
justement contre ce genre d' atteinte
qui l'a signalé comme très dangereuse
qui qui donnait effectivement les les
méthodes à utiliser au cas où ça se
produise il fallait il fallait donc une
personne à côté à ce moment-là bon pour
faire des gestes divers pour vous pour
éviter l'étouffement
[Musique]
je mange je suis tout seul et puis d'un
seul coup je dis merde ça sera trop
content je faisais pas je peux mourir
comme ça je m'étouffe les ambiances
vraiment trop con de de cronenbourg fang
il y a personne pour m'aider et puis à
ce moment-là ça ça se déclencher et puis
je commence par des problèmes pour
mastiquer jeu domestique est beaucoup
plus longtemps et j'ai du mal à l'avaler
et quelquefois j'ai oublié de recracher
carrément ce que je bouffe parce que
c'est la panique
[Musique]
premier at-il de sorte de phobie une
infinité
est ce que beaucoup de gens sont
phobique alors là aussi c'est assez
difficile de le savoir étant donné que
la plupart des phobiques se cache et
avoue très difficilement leur phobie
alors on connaît les phobiques qui ont
des phobies particulièrement gênante
donc ils peuvent pas se déplacer un
agoraphobe qui peut pas sortir de chez
lui va effectivement
se faire soigner va avoir recours aux
psychiatres donc on va le connaître mais
il existe des tas de gens qui sont
phobique de toutes choses et qu ils le
cachent soigneusement leur entourage et
phobies
sont principalement axés sur les objets
volants c'est les animaux volants
papillon nuit
oiseaux sur tout l'épisode houleux quel
effet ça vous fait quand vous touchez
une poule par exemple
ouais alors au niveau des sensations
c'est de tout de suite une sensation de
dégoût
l'envy de de la poussée violemment
et ne pas pouvoir garder le contact dans
les mains encore si elle ne bouge pas
c'est très bien qu'on lit desquels
sommet à faire quelques mouvements et
qui à ce bruissement flottement dead ça
devient très très vite insupportable et
il a
une association dans mon esprit qui
vient à ce contact des plumes c'est
l'association du
la violence
la violence du sang
[Musique]
vous même ce que vous estimez que vous
êtes au big de quelque chose comme tout
le monde j'ai aussi des phobies par
exemple la phobie des verres de contact
je porte des lunettes je crois je me
crois tout à fait incapable à l'heure
actuelle de porter des verres de contact
actuellement je suis secrétaire mais
disons que ça correspond pas vraiment à
ce que je voudrais faire et comme j'ai
la phobie du métro ça m'empêche un petit
peu de faire des bourdes qu'on fait
quand je suis accompagné ça m'est
complètement égal mais dès que je suis
toute seule je ne le prends pas que
price ne pas comment vous faites pour
vous déplacer je prends des taxis le bus
le bus vous pouvez oui depuis pas très
longtemps et pas très loin mais surtout
beaucoup taxi
c'est arrivé il ya plus de dix ans
tout d'un coup j'étais dans sur un
escalator très très profond j'ai eu un
étourdissement et non j'ai pris mon
métro quand même normalement et un quart
d'heure après j'avais à changement à
châtelet et sur le trottoir roulant
quelqu'un une crise d'épilepsie juste
devant moi et ça m'a vraiment
impressionné parce que j'ai fait le
rapprochement entre
l'étourdissement que j'avais juste avant
je me suis dit que je ne sais pas trop
ce que je me suis dit en fait j'ai pu
repris dutronc et pourquoi vous venez
pas avec quelqu'un vous simplifiera le
problème qui vous accompagnera le métro
le partout parce que je vais être
autonome que c'est complètement idiot de
prendre quelqu'un comme béquille vous
pouvoir vivre seul
[Musique]